Excuse Me Miss okay I think you're so
beautiful oh thank you I would honestly
try not to leave you on red to be honest
I would try not to leave you on red like
you gotta be honest with you what's your
what's your name I'm Michelle Michelle
nice to meet you can I take you on a
date sometime I was just wondering I
have a boyfriend uh he could make us
breakfast in the morning you can what
make us breakfast
he can make his breakfast in the morning
we covered this dude of course one of my
favorites confidence Chris yeah we
caught we covered this dude already yes
sir
because that's cool like when that ends
you know can I be like next in line
maybe
next in line that's me
can you take down my number because he's
just like well man said can I be next
can I have a turn please can I has a
turn
man when you're done with him or when
he's done with you can I can can I have
a little bit please please please can I
have the term take my number and call me
maybe
hey what's up Shawty
laughs
foreign
it went from
I went from confidence Chris to Chris
Chris to stupid Chris
the beating you could have got [__] my
guy in HD holding that camera having the
punch getting to you Jesus [__]
Christ I thought you were doing a tick
tock I was about to come on
that's your dad
[Music]
do you
you wait excuse me she's pretty as hell
like you're pretty as hell I was just my
friends
what's wrong I have a hard time watching
this and what you get lost some cringe
no y'all have a hard time I don't know
what it is I love seeing people bomb
that's my thing okay cool everything uh
we should chill sometimes I think
you know what that means we we should
chill like we should hang out no no we
can go together
um yeah
[Music]
well I mean like we should hang out yeah
I'm Chris yeah Chris Arya where are you
from I'm Chris
fired
he said oh they were blind to me yeah
yeah come to church with us
that's
[Music]
Chris what do you know about Christ huh
do I have to be a good boy to do that or
hey buddy
hey man she really about Jesus I don't
know if she really about it or this is
nice all right yeah yeah you want to go
out yeah you should come to church if
there's a way to reject it I just sent
him to a random Church you never go into
if it's the way to reject him I gotta
like that one yeah come to our church
yeah hey could I just be honest with you
could I just be honest with you what
well I always wanted to date a girl like
you but I haven't had the time to
I've just been busy and working on
myself and stuff like that so
well good luck with that yeah
we said this last time he's a troll hey
ma'am a bit random but um can I get your
number
my gosh it's like 55 years old I'm 55
years old you look like that my girl
can I get your number I'm 55.
and yo yo that's you at 55 let me play
that video man if that's your only issue
that you're 55 there's no issues my girl
what the [__] you mean I know she got a
PBR but that ass is crazy
yo yo that ass that is not real yo that
is crazy or she been maintaining all
that stuff there's no way at 55 you got
ads like that on a white girl that [__]
is pristine at 55 yeah
that ain't light that's a bbo
that's got to be a BBL
I forgot good genes and fitness but
hey it's not even his own she still did
a lot to work
because that's you at 55 ma'am you look
at least 12 to 15 years younger that's
not an argument what I'm 55. so
when you look like that that's not an
argument oh you're 55 perfect you can't
get pregnant that's exactly what I was
about to say
yeah I'm 55.
I'm about to give you 55 reasons to get
this yeah let's go huh I like them older
yeah you know maybe you could you could
teach me a thing or two that would be
great what do you think about that
as old as my son younger than my son oh
yeah
but you don't think I'm like cute or
Excuse Me Miss hey I know the gym isn't
the place to you know meet somebody but
uh we could just tell our parents we met
on Tinder or something
I know this isn't the place to like meet
somebody like the gym but we could just
tell our parents we made on Tinder
like another place to meet someone but
what but we could just tell our parents
we met on Tinder
yeah tennis like a baby now okay yeah so
can I take down your number I'm trying
to date anybody I'm not trying to date
you too we just go wash our cars or
something like that what do you mean
like wash your cars it's also working
cars wash our cars yeah
are you interested or no no oh okay we
have a good one
bro this is so cringe
this is a little cringe
this is so critical I know like this
[__] is a prank and everything and stuff
or else why would you film it like the
attendance to post it right do you think
that's intent I then I don't know what
the context is but this is cringe this
is super cringe oh let's pick up stuff
it's cringe as fun this is cringe she's
picking up these Hills let's keep
watching I'm just a good guy uh passing
through though okay yeah yeah so so a
lot of good guys out there no no no not
a good guy a cute guys sorry oh okay
because good guys always lose you know
no that's not true no I think that's
true the guy I'm dating is a good guy
and I like really love that about him is
he a Sim or
a simp
is that
she said what does that mean she's
that's when you know you're not
terminally online you live in the real
world you don't know about a lot of
these cringe words that everybody uses
online like the whole sip thing like
using that in reality is just cringe to
me now he's a Sim wait come on bro I
think you're like real fine to me
yeah what's your name I just Alexa
you're real beautiful to me what are you
up to my car is like on red but oh yeah
[Music]
what's his name
that pill it's
back like I like to pick up the yeah
exactly all right A Girl Like You Like
to go to like Malibu in today
you know probably Santa Monica and I and
then you could ride like probably the
ferris wheel or something
and you know what do you like to do
okay can I take down your number
[Music]
uh
see to me it's like Instagram me she's
not interested yeah yeah
well some of these women are definitely
into them they're just in relationship
yeah support supporter single Kings out
here doing the work
you're not a fan of confidence Chris no
you don't support uh him uh just
casually not insistingly having
conversation with women Chris yeah
sometimes dumb Chris seems like you
think this kind of thing is not good I
think it's cringe yeah yeah do you know
the insisting with women is bad
depends it depends on the context or it
depends on whether or not he's insisting
yeah right right and you feel like this
guy the way he's insisting is acceptable
I mean it's trolling so it's the context
of it I'm not saying like it's
apparently bad it's it's there's a
context to it the context is very
important yeah right when you understand
and you see what he does yeah I that's
what I get he's a huge troll right he's
destroying doing that for youth that's
my take you might not think that that's
on you but that's what I think he does
so
the part about this that I think is the
most weird
is that this [__] got spy
glasses and he's filming people and
putting them on tick tock
that's what I think it's weird
so these people just going about their
business and you run up on them and just
turn them into like your content like to
me that's a bit strange especially if
they're just out and about in their day
all right well what do you guys think
about confidence Chris do you think he's
a decent thing a bad bad do you think
he's causing women to be uncomfortable
what do you guys think about this kind
of guy and guys what do you think you're
like yo man he's shooting this shot or
do you think like now he's doing too
much like he just got to walk away when
she says I ain't interested